protecting our freedoms
about 12 30 dozens of mounties and
officers from police forces around the
lower mainland moved in and began
clearing away those blocking the border
how do you guys lift yourselves in the
mirror and go to sleep at night
[Music]
just good little boys taking orders
wearing your masks this isn't stopping
anything and every this is for
everybody's freedoms everyone's all
these police people here have families
too our taxes always fun to control so
it's all gold
and you guys need to leave and like i
said we're asking nicely once and anyway
the operation was methodical and mostly
peaceful though a handful were arrested
in the first few minutes
are you leaving
you guys are unbelievable
police formed a line and slowly started
moving demonstrators back
guys come on relax okay you're all here
for us
explaining that while they were allowed
to protest they're not allowed to do it
in a way that disrupts or blocks traffic
to and from the board
but as police were moving the
demonstrators back dozens more walked up
176th street to bolster the crowd
[Music]
brought the police clearing operation to
a standstill
come on
[Applause]
outnumbered ten to one at points police
held their line and for hours there was
this standoff just north of the border
where we could hear everything from
polite conversation
to insults and taunts directed at the
police doing their jobs
[Applause]